لا شك المملكه العربيه السعوديه بقياده
خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان حفظه
الله
ومعارضته ومسانده ولي عهده صاحب السمو
الملكي الامير محمد بلا شك ان ما حدث
في هذا العهد من يعني حزم
وهمم يعني قطع يدبر هذه التنظيمات عمل
يعني
مع عمل في ممكن اربع او خمس سنوات يوازي
عمل 40 او 50 سنه همم بلا شك انه قلل من
خطرها همم اصبحوا يتوارون لكن نقطه مهمه
وهي ان الصحوه همم جذورها وهمم هناك جمر
تحت الرماد ما زال واا من طبيعه هذه
التنظيمات انهم في مرحله همم الضغط والحزم
انهم يكمون حتى ترتاح لهم الفرصه الدليل
هذا الفكر كما ذكرت اساسه الفلسفه يمكن
قبل اكثر من 150 سنه اييه يعني على يد سيد
احمد خان ومحمد اقبال ثم جمال الدين
الافغاني حتى جاء حسن البنا والموجودي
واحيو هذا الفكر مرت الحركات سواء في
المشرق العربي او في همم
الدول الاخرى في العالم الاسلامي مرت ب
همم
يعني انكسارات ولكن مع ذلك تعود فهي تعود
وتتشكل وتلون لذلك يجب ان يبقى على حذر من
هذه التنظيمات وافكارها وتسللها هي تتشكل
يعني كانت تركز على ميادين معينه الان هي
تدخل في ميادين اخرى مثلا همم السوشيال
ميديا ميدان الجمعيات او المؤسسات المجتمع
همم الجمعيات الخيريه
كل هذه اصبحوا ينفذون من خلالها وان بشكل
غير مباشر طيب بالنسبه للقطاعات اللي
كانوا متوغلين فيها يعني انت سميت عدد من
القطاعات نعم حتى العسكريه السياسيه
تعليميه واقتصاديه ربما الاعلام
موجودين ما زال موجودين لكن بدرجه اقل
بدرجه كبيره جدا جدا يعني بالذات يعني
القطاعات الحساسه الامنيه والسياسيه بدرجه
كبيره جدا همم يكاد يكون تلاجه لكن قطع
التعليم ما زال ما زال في بواقي لان
القطاع عريض جدا